[Musique]
tu connais cette histoire d'éclair un
génie fou le monde se souvient bien sûr
du monstre pas de l'homme
c'est assez amusant de jouer l'archétype des
scientifiques de l'esprit j'ai la conviction que la
mort peut être une condition temporaire
c'est le récit d'une histoire qui  vous
pensez que vous savez être raconté d'une manière très
fraîche Igor et moi serons au
cœur même d'une entreprise scientifique qui
changera le monde
ai-je quelque chose
la relation entre moi et Dan l'
une des principales choses que j'ai essayées pour moi
au rôle  tout cela n'est pas grand chose faites
comme chez vous ne touchez à rien
James est un génie incroyable nous nous
faisons beaucoup rire
Daniel Radcliffe est l'enthousiasme est
contagieux d'être traqué par la police
et poursuivi par des monstres
si vous allez vous concentrer sur le
côté obscur quand vous voyez James être la balle verte,
cela me donne plus de confiance pour
jouer aussi il y a beaucoup de laboratoires
il y a beaucoup d'action il y a un
divertissement total moins plutôt évident
vous